and you had some bad  people in if you look at what happened  at the capitol you had some bad people  that were not patriots at all and they  came from other places including antifa  and including others and they let a lot  of people astray they don't want to  cover that yeah i like how he says  antifa  antifa  um  so that trump is saying two things  his supporters who are not criminals  their patriots aren't being treated well  and the truth that a lot of the rioters  where antifa  is not being covered and those people  are not being prosecuted there's no  evidence for any of this this is lies  all the way down i hope that you know  that